the other sort of backdoor intervention
that i've always found to be
unbelievably powerful is putting
yourself in the position of adding value
to someone else it's unbelievably
empowering it puts you in the position
of being a giver like what advice would
you give to somebody in this moment it's
also a wellspring of motivation
you're a practicing psychiatrist
what have been some of the most common
trends that you've seen over the last
year
interestingly at the very beginning of
the pandemic i was really worried about
some of my patients who have a lot of
anxiety
and
here's what happened is
a lot of them felt unbelievably prepared
for the pandemic they told me that they
were giving advice to their that their
worried well friends
who you know typically would say to them
why are you so anxious what worries you
all the time you know you should come
out more
and it was really interesting that they
i think they had a lot of strategies
that they use they had a lot of you know
they would use cbt
they
sort of knew how to manage their anxiety
and so they found themselves in this
position of being advice givers and that
their experience was sort of helping
somebody else and as one of my patients
said to me like you know i've been doing
this all my life like i've been ready
for this you know for the past 20 years
and so i'm you know ready to go and
and i think that that was a surprise for
sure um you know you know and giving
them sort of some strength though but of
course i mean uncertainty was obviously
what was really
difficult for people but what i tried to
work with them on is how certainty is
such an illusion anyway and what we sort
of imagine in our lives and being able
to predict what tomorrow's going to be
so
i i my hope is that emerging from this
that there has been some growth some
focus on you know what has one gained um
in it and even some you know
post-traumatic growth is that we've
actually seen i i don't you know you can
only really talk about post-traumatic
growth in
afterwards um is an outcome and i think
we're very much mid pandemic right now
so it's hard to you know look at we
can't really say in in retrospect but
i've had them sort of working what are
the ways what are the factors that
contribute to post-traumatic growth then
we can get into that or we can um we can
talk about that later
what about
lockdown shame have you seen any people
feeling like they should have
could have would have done more i
haven't been as productive as i as i
ought to have been
there's been so much of that like regret
and there's nothing worse than sort of
that that guilt um like you know that
that could you know why didn't i manage
you know learn how to speak mandarin why
didn't i you know
learn how to
somebody on your podcast was saying they
like climb mount everest on their
staircase or something i mean what an
accomplishment but you know i think a
lot of people think god i just did
nothing you know and i didn't get
anything done but that has so much to do
with the way our brains work is that
we're we're so good at
noticing what is left undone
right like we're so good at seeing what
we haven't completed and there was a
researcher in vienna in the 1930s um
dr zygarnick who noticed that when
waiters were working in in restaurants
and serving tables
they you know had an amazing ability to
remember the orders the multiple orders
that were open
and though what they
once an order was completed and people
would pay the check and left
it would just be obliterated from their
memory they had no idea like if you said
to them what did those people have again
they would have no idea but they could
remember the orders that were sort of
half complete like that person still
needs a coffee that one needs some cake
and so what this is is our
we're so good at remembering sort of
what's undone but not particularly good
at remembering what we've accomplished
and
so i mean i think this can work for us
and against us too and it can work for
you know against us when it comes to
regret like why didn't i do this or i
had on my to-do list to write that
screenplay to get in shape to quit
smoking and all those things but we're
really bad at focusing on what we have
completed and again that's an
intentional deployment issue right i
mean it's like how what are you seeing
and if you do sort of ask yourself to
remind yourself like what did i check
off that list today and i think that can
sort of help people just getting through
the pandemic you know maybe did you
you know did you speak more to your kids
than you ever have before did you like
deepen your relationship with your
spouse during this period like what what
maybe did you accomplish and i think
refocusing attention is a really big
part of that it's got to be so conscious
though right like you're not going to do
that just on a whim you're not going to
remember that you spoke to your kids a
little bit more or got to spend some
more time with your spouse
but forget the fact that you didn't get
in shape or didn't learn mandarin like
it's got to be quite effortful
well that's what i might just find to be
just so interesting about like how our
brains work anyway is how our
our inability to sort of clock the good
stuff and we you know unless you're sort
of effortful about it and there's this
wonderful i think philosopher at the
university of chicago and he calls it
delight hunting
and unless you're actually registering
things that are beautiful or
you know sort of interesting
they'll just sort of pass through you
and those sort of you won't even filter
them but if you even just write it down
or like wow that was sort of a cool bird
i just saw or like that tasted so good
that thing i just ate
and you share it with somebody else it
does shift it becomes this uplift and we
know that positive emotions kind of help
buffer you know we're talking about a
lot of like hassles and things like that
when you just experience those positive
emotions that you do have like a
different level like a scaffolding
against just the annoyances that are
just flying at you every day doesn't
rick hansen say something similar to
that in hardwiring happiness i'm sure
that he talks about the fact that when
you do something nice or that you're
proud of you need to sit with it in your
mind for 10 seconds and that that
actually is long enough to lay down the
myelin sheaths around the neural
pathways and then over time it actually
becomes easier to be more and more
grateful but yeah i mean
here's a perfect example
think about
the last thing
that you didn't complete and how long
you ruminated over that and then think
about the last thing that you did
complete and think about how fleetingly
you allowed that sensation to occur it
was more like a
relief
than pleasure
whereas on the other side it's more like
guilt or shame
as opposed to encouragement so the bad
things are always felt much more harshly
and they last longer and then the good
things are so much more brief
and they don't have as much impact
no and so how do we sort of refocus our
attention to and to be more deliberate
about it because it just won't sit with
us i mean i can tell you about the
thousand things i'm bad at you know you
go and you have a conversation with your
you know boss or your manager and
they'll tell you you know some pretty
nice things the only thing you'll
remember is the criticism and that's
just how our brains work and in some
ways it can be kind of you know
productive too it's sort of that's you
know knowing what's unfinished like that
unfinished business is maybe what you
what does what will motivate you um to
focus on and so maybe you won't
procrastinate as much but
i think being deliberate about delight
is really really important and in
sharing it with someone else because
then it does imprint somehow i think on
your brain i think it is the myelin
sheaths that it's
it's creating a memory of it going
beyond that fleeting moment because
otherwise we're just tumble weeds we're
just kind of being blown about by all
these other whims and and sort of at the
mercy of our you know
brains that are afraid of anything
negative so um yeah i'm really
interested in how do you clock delight
what are micro stresses
micro stressors
are a really potent form of stress and i
think we tend to ignore them they're the
everyday like hassles and frustrations
like the
just those annoyances that you can't
control it's the traffic jam it's your
spilled coffee it's just those
irritations
and you know we often think that the
it's really like the big life events
that are the most distressing um to us
and that take the most out of us in the
biggest toll
well it turns out that actually we're
pretty resilient to most of those to
loss to change to inflection points and
most of the research suggests that we're
we
we recover we bounce back from those
even um
for instance after 9 11 in in new york
city there was an expectation that
people
would have post um you know traumatic
stress disorder and there'd be a huge
amount of resources that were earmarked
for treatment
turned out six months later
it was minimal
and so we know that that resilience is
actually the default not um to those big
life events but to those little stuff
that accumulation of those micro
stressors that happen every single day
they they accumulate they grow and look
nobody's bringing you a casserole
because you got stuck in a traffic jam
right like nobody's like oh tell me more
about your delayed flight that sounds so
interesting so i think you don't have
the social support around it um but
all these studies show that those little
hassles and micro stressors add up so
much and take the biggest toll on your
physical health and also on your mental
health cardiovascular um it takes
cardiovascular toll but also on your um
immune system like they know uh
i think it's a carnegie mellon
university um it's dr cohen there and
he'll take the flu virus and you know to
his poor graduate students they get you
know on a q-tip they get the flu virus
stuck up their nose
and and you know then he measures you
know puts them basically in a like hotel
room and measures who comes down with
the flu and who doesn't well during
periods of stress like before exams and
um you know when they're sort of
stressed out they're much more likely to
come down with the symptoms of the flu
to feel worse like their um feelings are
worse about it and even the pork brad
students have to measure
their tissues with the amount of snot
inside them and that sort of determines
how how you know how symptomatic they
are but when they've just come back from
vacation and this happens they don't
feel like they are much more less likely
to get sick so i think those those who
have a lot of daily stress in their
lives um you know even after
watching like a football game or
something and your team loses you you
might you're actually also still more
vulnerable to catching a cold
but also people who report more stress
in their daily lives are much more
likely long-term to have to have
depression or anxiety so i i feel that
it's something that we don't pay enough
attention to and instead of the big our
resilience that that is our sort of
default i think we need more little art
resilience um to deal with the micro
stressors
seems quite counter-intuitive that i
think i would need quite a bit of
convincing to
believe that compounding coffee spills
over a period of time would it would
equate to a divorce but
what i'm going to guess is that most of
the big challenges that you come up
against the loss the financial problems
the job changes
the vast majority of those are going to
be either out of your control or only
sort of analogously within your control
and that means that actually the way
that you do deal with the coffee spills
and all of the rest of it is going to
give you perhaps a little bit more in
the tank so that you can deal with the
big life events when they come
i think exactly what you're saying like
what's in the tank because because we
know even with trauma or even with
everyday stress it's your perception of
it it's not at the event itself it's how
you experience it to be do you is this a
um
you know something that's truly like not
everybody will have the same response
that you will and i
um had a patient years ago who had a lot
of anxiety and um he sort of performance
anxiety and he had been asked to you
know he'd been promoted and he needed to
give talks every
week to his um to his staff and he
he would say the worst thing would
happen to me you know whenever every
like monday like you know i'm just
sweating my heart's racing i just can't
breathe i've got like these beads of
sweat pouring down my face my palms are
all sweaty and shaky it's just the worst
thing ever
and one day he was watching bruce
springsteen on like a talk show and he's
bruce springsteen's being asked like
what's it like to perform in front of 20
000 people and bruce says you know it's
just the best feeling you know my
heart's racing
you know my hands get all clammy and
sweaty my knees are shaking you know
i've got these butterflies in my stomach
and i know it's my body telling me that
i am ready to rock
and so you have these almost identical
physiological experiences and yet
completely different interpretations of
them and so it really was sort of this
insight for my patient at the time
thinking well wait a minute like maybe
is this my like information instead from
my body and and noticing how that
interpretation or perception of
something makes it stressful or not and
then also having as you say that fuel in
the tank like have you slept well are
you moving are you eating well you know
did you have a fight with your spouse on
the way out the door this morning you
know or what are you doing to kind of
create that scaffolding and that buffer
around you is that what you mean when
you say discomfort is data
absolutely you know i'm
i
i studied positive psychology
i you know i have a degree in psychiatry
and i went to medical school but then i
started positive psychology but i'm not
i i'm not a big believer believer in
like the rainbows and unicorns like some
stuff sucks
and you know i i think there's an
intolerance uh right now of negative
emotions they're sort of like well you
gotta just gotta either treat it take a
we got a pill for that or you know
um people don't wanna really hear about
it in some way so
it's so important i think negative
emotions are so valuable and to even
it's the only way you learn also like if
you are interesting studies looking at
people who just like kind of don't
process it and just kind of sweep it
under the rug and move on like they
don't learn from them and if you
actually want to
change and grow and um and sort of at
least grow in the right direction you've
got to be processing these negative
emotions and feeling what you feel
there's a you know
what there's a lot of research right now
looking at granularity so you don't just
like trying not to just look at like an
overwhelming feel of like not good like
what specifically are you feeling right
now can you put that into words is there
an amazing word that does this for you
like i don't speak german but german has
amazing words for everything that i
think the english language fails
miserably at but once you can pinpoint
that thing it becomes a little bit less
overwhelming it's less personal it feels
less pervasive and less permanent and um
you can actually then
you sort of narrow it down put that
spotlight on it and now say okay now
what like what's the action you're going
to take about it and it's less
paralyzing um i think then when you just
have that overall feeling of badness
because i think we have a lot to learn
from negative emotions they're very
helpful i'm a big fan
sam harris has a thought experiment
where he talks about reframing an
experience that's going on within the
body or within the mind he says
imagine that you've just completed a
workout a hard high intensity interval
session or something and your heart
rate's high and your body's unbelievably
hot super uncomfortable you're sweating
everywhere you're panting you can't
breathe you're red in the face you want
to lie on the floor
if that just happened spontaneously as
you were sat in your car you would feel
terrified you'd think i'm having a heart
attack this is there is something
unbelievably wrong here and yet people
go to the gym literally to chase that
feeling that's what they're after so if
that doesn't show that framing is is
everything and that leaning into
discomfort like one of the mantras that
i've learned over the last year is
that the the reason that you're here is
for the discomfort
so when you feel that
just reminding yourself look this is why
you're here when you're in the gym and
your legs start to burn
this is why you're here when you're
training and you start to run out of
breath this is why you're here when
you're doing a a
an assignment for university or
completing a presentation for work and
it gets difficult that's the reason that
you're doing it that is the proximal
zone of development that's you pushing
the boundaries of what you can do it's
getting beyond your current if all it
was was comfort there would be no growth
but inevitably the the first
reflex response to something that's
uncomfortable is i don't like this i
want it to stop i'm
tired stupid dumb not fit enough not
smart enough not clever enough not er
erudite enough whatever it might be i
don't have the things the requisite
skills
it should be easier
but when you concede okay discomfort
isn't just a bug it's a feature
and on top of that
it's why you're here like you're
literally here to get to the discomfort
that's the signal of growth as soon as
you realize that i think everything
changes
caveat to that
i'm still really dramatic during every
workout that i ever do i still
procrastinate all the time
my point is that when you can remain
metacognizant enough to allow that to
happen
it's it's a game changer
well yes and i think that um
i think one of your podcasts i was
listening to was just the act of
standing in line like what's more
painful than that and just like the
thought of just standing in lines and
waiting without even even when you get
to the front you just go to the back
again but actually i think that's where
you sort of see it is all a process and
not so outcome driven and
you know i'm thinking of kelly lambert
who does this cool um research at the
university of richmond and she studies
rats that we have an uncanny resemblance
i think two rats in many ways and when
you
you give rats apparently they love froot
loops it's like the greatest rat delight
in the world and so
some rats she um like sort of buries
this fruit loop once a day under all
their bedding and they have to like
you know go rummaging through this their
their beds to get it and it takes work
it's a little bit uncomfortable but they
push themselves to do this and then the
other rats they're just basically handed
their froot loop on a silver platter and
she calls them her trust fund rats
and so when these rats though are
challenged in some way uh like they're
put in a different kind of cage or
they're asked to swim apparently rats
don't really like to swim that much but
um they will do it
the trust fund rats immediately give up
like they have no like they're just like
ah i'm done i can't figure it out
whereas the ones who have been used to
sort of being uncomfortable and
rummaging and putting this sort of
effortful behavior into getting their
froot loop are much more likely to
persevere like they try many more times
to to get into to to reach the fruit
loop and stuff and so i think there is
um maybe we are we have a lot to think
about with the rats but actually putting
ourselves in those places of of
discomfort and
unease and look it's it's not where like
i think our society goes and certainly
like in child um care these days it's
all about like are you comfortable it's
like the helicopter the snow plow the
um anything to
avoid discomfort or stress and you know
as we know there's i mean there is a
good amount of stress that um yurky's
dodson curve where you look at like
where our peak performance is when we're
a little bit stressed out um so so uh
like what's the right dose it's
obviously different for different people
and it has a lot to do with what you
said filling up your tank to begin with
what can people do if they're having a
crap day
let's say that someone's just
it's been micro stressor after micro
stressor the coffee the dog poo the on
the shoe the bad conversation with the
boss what should people do
well i think europe so sometimes our
inclination in those moments i know mine
is is just to be like i need to order
pizza or have like a bottle of wine and
i'm going to cancel my plans with
friends and you know binge watch tv and
stay up late at night i'm constantly
amazed by our ability to undermine our
well-being and actually do the very
opposite of the thing we you know would
actually would make us feel strong in
those moments but that's exactly when it
is those moments to think of like okay
what would make me feel strong here and
it is usually like what are you gonna
eat for dinner tonight are you do you
really need to have that drink you know
or that vodka at this moment
go to the gym
you know but make it you know we know
with behaviors that whatever it is that
you want to do
make it easier on yourself lower the
activation energy to um for the thing
that you want to do if you already have
your sneakers on you know if you are
ready or like you know you've got like
your your gym clothes on you're much
more likely to go or your gym bags
packed to go to the gym than if you have
to like go through the motions of
getting it google had done that cool
experiment they used to give all of the
i think employees you could have like
endless access to m ms and so you were
like apparently people at google were
eating so many m ms and they were
displayed in these beautiful like glass
jars in every kitchen like or on every
floor
and so they kind of have this m m
problem they're like what do we do
and they had these behavioral scientists
come in
and they said well if you get rid of the
m m's people will be really pissed off
and there'll be a mutiny but
why don't we just put the healthier
snacks a little bit lower down on the
shelves and um you know so they're kind
of within reach and let's put those
beautiful m ms in an opaque container
really like out of reach and people are
so lazy to begin with so you know it
just decreased i think eminem
consumption by about 70
so whatever is the behavior that you
want to do at the beginning of the day
you can't rely on motivation we know
motivation comes and goes you might be
like in the morning you're so motivated
to go to the gym and eat well and do all
those things you want to do but at the
end of the day you might not be so make
it easier to do the behavior you want
and then you're much more likely to
follow through with it what was that
harvard study about different activities
that reduce stress
oh that was a great i mean i was
fascinated by this you know so in
medical school you know i was so focused
on what was going wrong with people and
that's what you do it's all about
diagnosing people's problems and kind of
coming up with them and like here i've
got a medication for that or maybe you
should talk to somebody you you know
percuss um
uh you know lungs you palpate prostates
you auscultate abdomens but and then in
medical school i did the same thing
palpate prostate
you palpate prostates truly that's
something
is the most it's that's the most
diplomatic way that i've ever heard to
talk about putting your finger up
someone's bomb
well it's actually they hire actors god
bless them to come in and let like us
like a class of medical students come in
and practice on them i mean they i mean
i guess
actors
come in
what everybody gets to have a go
i think actually there were three of
them the year that i did it but yeah
i was 100 people and
33.3 fingers
per person you are kidding me this isn't
good
this isn't true
they were really good sports and we had
to sort of go through like the role
playing of like how are you it's nice to
see you today and
it was um oh my god that's how you do it
imagine you do you don't really want
someone ever doing it in the past right
i just think like
imagine that being your job
okay honey like you off off to work
today what job have you got on to is it
more work on the soap opera no actually
i've got 33.3 people sticking the finger
at my ass uh at the front of a lecture
theater
well let's reframe that for a second
like you are helping educate all these
kids you know these medical students
come on
limited cognitive reappraisal maybe yeah
i think so i think i think my limit
would be
less than 33.3 fingers
anyway
so yes you you
that is so bizarre that's that's really
thrown me
i'm sorry for the curveball here we
could have a lot to talk about from
medical school but no so going back into
like you know what what could make
somebody feel less bad but if you look
at these these studies um you know this
harvard study asking people like
actually what gives you an uplift what
makes you feel good what makes you feel
strong it was
you know working um on a hobby playing
with my dog you know going to the gym
hanging out with my friends um you know
and of course people are so much happier
it's called the weekend effect people
are typically happier on the weekends um
for obvious reasons and yeah like
down down down on the list was maybe
talking about my problems or seeing a
therapist or taking medication but the
stuff that actually makes you feel good
isn't the opposite like it's just not an
absence of of stuff that makes you feel
bad doesn't make you feel strong
and you can treat people and you can
make people less miserable but it
doesn't mean they're having a good day
and you speak to anybody who has anxiety
or any mental illness they yes they want
more you know better medications or
better understanding but they just want
to have a better day
and the things that actually
allow for that um
are above and beyond the things that
make us less miserable
so how do you build those uplifts into
your everyday life and a big part of
that i always ask patients when they
come to see me
you know what are like the three things
that you value most in life you know and
whatever those are write them down
and then okay how do you spend your time
how do you spend your saturday like how
do you spend your free time and it's
there's often this like gulf between
what people care about and what really
matters to them and then actually what
they do
and i think closing
that gap is really the essence of
resilience you know if you can walk your
walk a little bit more and be
intentional
about that and there are a lot of
different strategies to
you know i think it
like happiness isn't in your head it's
in the actions you take and the
connections you make and how you
participate right so i think really the
the essence of that little our
resilience is having people feel that
they are are um true to what they value
and just kind of integrating that more
into their daily lives just having a
look at the
at the chart you've got here for that
study so 94 of people
uh reported the effectiveness the most
effective way to reduce stress levels
uh was regularly spending time outdoors
94 regularly spent time on a hobby 93
regularly exercised 89
regularly spent time with a pet 87 i can
completely see that regularly meditated
or prayed 85 percent that's surprising
um i wouldn't have put that so high
regularly spent time with friends and
family 83
so yeah regularly got a full night sleep
76
so yeah it's just um
it's like it's so unsexy so many of the
solutions to little stresses and stuff
like that
what do you think
what are some of the ways that people
get it wrong like how do people deal
with stress
really poorly in your experience
you know i think our
that sort of negative coping it is sort
of
typically like reaching for that drink
or i think some of those lifestyle
factors um that that really give us that
you know immediate like sense of relief
or even sense of control
but ultimately like i always think of it
it's like kind of cotton candy for the
soul like it's just the stuff that
actually makes you feel horrible
and the i mean i agree with you and
there's a lot of um
like a lot of the stuff is super unsexy
like oh go outside or whatever and but
that you've got them like sometimes i
think the wellness industry that's
telling us well you can download it you
can you know juice it you can buy it you
know and that all of these things like
these are the solutions to your problems
you need to eat pray love your way um to
that place of strength and a lot of
these solutions are actually available
in your everyday life like they're there
it's just the question of are you
taking them are you kind of living those
values what are you doing that are kind
of what are you doing to create those
uplifts in your daily life and so you
don't have to pay for it you don't have
to move to india and meditate um but you
can even if going outside i mean you
know there's a lot of evidence that we
have nature deficit disorder ndd and
that we are not spending enough time
outside and i think our
our brains like we are biophilic like we
need to be outside and i think in nature
and
i think in japan they call it forest
bathing it's just that sense of being
outdoors and you know rumination you
know we're talking about that is
an on-ramp to depression when you just
have that
you know almost like you're chewing your
cub like a cow like you just keep
thinking about like why did i say this
why you know why did i do this and one
of the best interventions for rumination
is being outdoors um so i think that
that and being just in a green space is
so helpful for all of us we know that
patients who are recovering from surgery
um do it much more quickly when they
have a window to look out at in a tree
they require less pain medication uh and
we really underestimate even like kids
who go to school through a park um and
spend time outdoors rather than like in
a car a bus
have fewer symptoms of like attentional
issues is reported by their teachers so
i think any way
you can increase that time you spend
outdoors and even
have maybe some proximity to all
um is really interesting looking at
studies of natural language with like a
people when they're in like the center
of a park
and they're talking the the words they
use are much happier they're they're the
equivalent of what the researchers said
of what people use on christmas um when
they're actually in a natural space like
that so i think that that is a really
powerful intervention i mean i literally
prescribe going to parks um and spending
time outdoors especially during kobet
it's astonishing yale did the study on
last year was before the pandemic uh and
i think the average uh american spends
less than i think it was four hours
outside a week
and it was just astonishing how little
we spend out time outdoors people want
to but they just don't do it you know
and i think all of our entertainment is
indoors and on screens and stuff so i
think again just trying to kind of get
outside and we know that from all these
studies like the sports people do like
the the that they do when they do it
with a friend and they do it outdoors
they have fewer mental health days
do you have any idea what the optimal
dose of being outdoors is or where this
sort of curve begins to kick in is half
an hour enough is an hour enough
i think 20 minutes is enough
you know and i think sometimes it sounds
really overwhelming like oh i've got to
go outside for three hours you know i
mean of course not and that's
unrealistic but i think any time you can
and
again it's like gets down to like even
you'll be like sitting at your desk and
thinking like oh i can't do this why
should i go outside for 20 minutes um
and the only way
that i even get myself to go outside is
often if i know i'm meeting somebody
outside and they're going to be there
and i'm just going to be like it's just
not being a flake like how do you get
yourself to go somewhere and i think
when you
you pair it with something else and you
don't like or like
i'll say it's the only time i can you
know listen to the chris williamson
podcast is if i'm outside you know like
if you do it with something that's
temptation bundling um and when you do
the thing that you want to do when you
pair it with something that you don't
really want to do like go outside you're
much more likely to do it same reason
for getting a dog right you've got to
walk the dog dog needs walking walking
is outside sometimes you could go walk
the dog with somebody else that also
owns a dog playing a team sport that's
outside that's exercise that's other
people that's socializing yeah
downstream from that is interesting so
you're talking about sort of these
uplifts and these upward spirals here
what about if someone's on the other
side of the curve what if someone's
having a downward spiral and they've got
sort of negative rumination have you got
any suggestions about how they can
patent interrupt
that and kind of have a reset and then
bounce back out
i mean one of the best interventions
that we know for mental health that i
was not taught in medical school or in
psychiatry residency is movement you
know there was a study done in 2009 at
duke where they had half the people who
had mild symptoms of depression
um that were given a medication i think
um might have even been zoloft and the
other half were given a prescription to
walk on a treadmill for 30
minutes
i think four days a week
everybody felt better within about six
weeks but nine months later the the
treadmill group was less much less
likely to have relapsed and i think it's
such a powerful intervention is giving
um is is movement and ideally i'd say
being outside that study was on a
treadmill but it's so important to just
move your body and it's it's hard to get
yourself to do and you might not be feel
like doing it the other sort of backdoor
intervention that i've always found to
be unbelievably powerful
is putting whatever yourself in the
position of adding value to someone else
you know like what could you the best
honestly one of the best antidotes for
stress is contributing to something else
doing something for somebody else it's
unbelievably empowering it puts you in
the position of being a giver like what
advice would you give to somebody in
this moment um
and i think that that is an incredibly
powerful way to
feel like you have some sense of
efficacy right like that you feel like
whatever your experience is matters
tremendously it's also a
wellspring of motivation you know when
you ask people you know most people have
the information that they they need
about how to lose weight or save money
or um you know do behaviors they want to
do so you don't really need to educate
them and i think we spend too much time
from a public health perspective
focusing on like let's give these people
information let's show them how to do it
and it's actually when that you know if
you ask them like what advice would you
give could you write that down because
you know
you you
people then not only i think are the
recipients of their advice better off
and they learn something but also
they themselves what you kind of want to
walk your walk and stay true to your
values and sort of do as you say
so i i find that's one of the best ways
to
increase your um you know your your
your sense of self efficacy and also
like your motivation it's you know
you know the marshmallow study of those
kids when they were five years old
actually when a study done last year was
looking at little kids who were saying
well if you can do this you have a
partner so you if you don't eat the
marshmallow um then you and your partner
both get another one
when they have that partner they're much
more likely to follow through and i
think again it just taps into your
motivation when you're doing something
with somebody um or for somebody else
but a lot of people at the moment have
got [ __ ] jobs they've got
things that
they know
probably is just crunching numbers
maybe there's a robot that's coming down
the pipe that's gonna take that off them
within the next couple of decades maybe
they don't feel connected with it
perhaps they don't have a family yet or
perhaps they've struggled with breakups
from families and stuff like that what
about these people like how how are you
supposed to add value when inherently
the things that you feel like you do on
a daily basis don't add that much value
to you
but i guess it goes down to i mean how
are you framing that whatever you're
doing i mean i think we can think of
christopher wren the architect who would
say you know when talking about building
um the cathedral saying you know are you
you know you ask three people what are
you doing they're doing the exact same
job and you know one man says i'm laying
bricks one says i'm building a wall one
sells i build one says i'm building a
cathedral so i think your mindset about
whatever you're doing it probably is
adding value somehow to you know what
people are doing and i think we
certainly saw that in the pandemic of
you know frontline workers who i think
got tremendous like outpourings of
gratitude that was so well deserved for
for you know the value that they add
every single day to people's lives but
so maybe take a look at what you're
doing is there a way do you is there any
positive impact this has on anybody else
you know looking at i know that um
studies looking at people who work in
hospitals if you just sort of your job
description limits you to like okay i am
a janitor i'm on the housekeeping staff
or do you actually feel like you're part
of this organization and part of the
health of this institution the health of
these human beings and you know people i
think are much more invested in what
they're doing um but then outside of
that there's so many other ways you can
add value in in in life and you probably
are adding value to other people's lives
and maybe not even thinking about it um
and so i think being present in in that
way and we often say like oh where's
your motivation to do something
sometimes it's for someone else i'd have
this patient who was dying to quit
smoking and you know he had all the
information he knew
all the reasons why he should quit
smoking and he could run faster and it
would be good for his health and to live
longer the only thing that got him to
stop one day was he was at like a family
meal with his nephew
and he was getting up to go outside and
have a cigarette and his nephew took
like a breadstick and was like can i
come with you and pretended to start
smoking too and he was like that's it i
can't do this if i'm that role model for
this kid you know so i think we
sometimes underestimate the impact we
have on other people for positively and
negatively
what's being on you
well i think people we're told all the
time you have to be yourself like oh be
yourself it's great you know this is
good advice and i i used to not love
public speaking and i would sort of when
someone be like oh you're gonna get up
in front of like you know an audience
and the best thing just be yourself and
you'll be great like go out there and
like being myself i would run out the
door and like you know pass like set off
the fire alarms and so
being yourself isn't the best advice
because a who is the real you is there
any true you that's in there we're all
in the process of becoming constantly
we're all changing hopefully in the
direction of goodness um that we can
shape a little bit but instead of like
being yourself what's the opposite of
the thing that you feel like doing what
would that be and i think that is you
were asking like if somebody's having a
really [ __ ] day like what do you like
what's the opposite of the thing you
feel like doing like maybe that is going
for a run maybe that is calling you know
a friend of yours maybe that is showing
up um you know with your friends
somewhere and i think being on you and
one way to kind of you know there's a
lot of research around like what they
call self distancing like when you're
somebody says to you like how are you
feeling right now you're having a really
bad day tell me about it and you're like
literally like you sort of start stewing
in it well i you know this is what
happened and that's what happened you're
sort of you're rehashing it and that
leads to rumination but when you can
self-distance and say you know how would
a fly on the wall describe that or um
you know if you were talking to a friend
what advice would you give them or what
would your future self tell you to do in
this moment any opportunity you can have
to sort of
gain some distance and one
way of doing that i think is when you
you can be sort of unused by thinking
who's somebody you admire what would
they do in this moment because it can
actually get you closer to the version
of yourself you'd like to be
and i think we we focus so much on like
be authentic and being authentic can
sometimes bring out the worst in us i
mean i know like it depends on like
which version of ourselves we are
but you know the studies looking at
people asking them to be creative
imagining yourself to be a creative poet
you're much more likely to be creative i
mean i think most people think of
creativity something like you're you're
creative or you're not uh other studies
looking at people who you know just even
putting on an article of clothing people
were told to put on like a doctor's coat
and to solve math problems they're much
more likely to persevere than they think
it's an artist's mock so what's somebody
i mean we don't all need to go out and
buy like you know superhero capes but
would somebody who you admire what would
chris williamson do right now like how
could i you know
do not propose to people as something as
a strategy that they should take but i
mean it's interesting right because
there is a paradox going on here that
being your true self speaking your truth
forward finding what it is in you that
you can resonate with the world these
are things that we champion and yet on
the flip side of that
it does feel like there's something to
fake it until you make it the mamba
mentality which kobe bryant popularized
beyonce she had a i can't remember what
her alias was called but she had like
some super villain version of herself
that was able to go out on stage and
wasn't scared and wasn't worried and
stuff like that
so there's definitely something going on
here i think that the the distancing is
is probably part of it that if you have
a
a mode that you're able to step into
where
the limitations perhaps that plague your
day-to-day life no longer exist
you do create a little bit of of
distance between the two i'd be very
interested to see
who is more effective long-term about
whether or not the success rate of
somebody that's more integrated i.e sort
of real person is performing person or
somebody that's more detached and has
these two sort of disparate versions be
very interested to see sort of over time
who ends up in a best in a better place
because i can see
problems with both and i can see
advantages for both right you're going
to be able to siphon off some of the
challenges and the difficulties that you
have if you go mambo mentality mode
but
i wonder whether you're losing out on
bleeding some of the lessons that you
get from those challenges back across
into your real life i wonder whether
you're kind of almost acting in contrast
or in conflict with yourself sometimes
whether or not imposter syndrome is more
likely to creep in because you don't
feel like you when you're up on stage
that it's just
samantha speaker as opposed to samantha
boardman you know like i wonder how that
would play out but
in my experience i would definitely say
that
considering
yourself to be like the kind of person
that you want to be when you're up
against stresses you know what is the
the idealistic version of me where i
want to get to what would that person do
and then when it comes to the more
interpersonal stuff like asking yourself
questions
speaking to yourself how you would speak
to a person that you're supposed to care
about
is
it's a superpower like it literally is
one of the best things that you can do
and
you see
one of the questions i had people ask
during lockdown when everyone was locked
in and there was only a small number of
things that they could do
what would have had to have happened by
the end of lockdown for you to look back
on lockdown and consider it a success
like you've got the entire world at your
disposal except for the fact that you
can't leave your house like what would
it have to be
and that question is so blindingly
obvious because you go well
it's almost like it's like i'm watching
my own life play out in front of me and
then i just think what would it have to
be and that question clears away so many
of the challenges and the same thing
treat yourself as if you are someone
you're responsible for helping
those two ways of framing things i think
give us a lot of perspective
what gives such clarity and i think in a
way that maybe the the idea of maybe
being like sort of authentic in your
true self that
you are like i think in those moments
that we have like cognitive flexibility
and they're able to like sort of because
we we are
multiple selves ultimately you know in
in our everyday lives and it's funny you
say that about that i love that question
you're asking people like how did the
pandemic have been a success
uh i know i know a lot of people and
therapists do it like at the beginning
of each day if you ask your patients to
write down like you know fast forward to
the end of today what would have made
today a success and write that down like
today i had an amazing conversation with
my son i you know got this this and this
done at work i you know and so you can
sort of look back on things and i think
we look at cbt as something that's sort
of reframing in the past but i think
actually having a future orientation is
really valuable for people too and it's
sort of like what are you looking
forward to this week how do you want to
feel next time when you come in and see
me in the session like what do you feel
you know what do you want to tell me
about um
and uh there's a gabriel ottensen who's
for nyu who's done
a lot of work on
you know people who just think positive
all the time and she's german and she's
when she came to america she didn't
understand she's like all this like
think positive stuff i don't get it is
it really that helpful and she was
really interested in in like sort of
teasing that out and opening and people
who just like thought positive were
actually
less likely to persevere and you know
do the thing that they wanted to do
yes a hundred percent
so what are then so she calls it um so
how do you
you know it's not just thinking like oh
everything's going to turn out well this
isn't the secret it is then
well you know what are what are the
things that are going to get in the way
of that and so you actually it's not
just about like having some insight or
thinking like everything's going to turn
out really well it's okay how can i
actually you know operationalize this
and she calls it whoop goals w-o-o-p
and so the w stands for okay what's your
wish like my wishes that i'm going to go
to the gym this afternoon my wishes i'm
going to look at my phone less and then
what would be the outcome of that is the
next the first o
you know and like how would you really
feel like really think about like close
your eyes and think about how that would
feel to you
and then the next o is okay then what is
the obstacle what's the thing that's
going to get in the way of you doing
that and then the p is okay what's your
plan
you know and i think there you are
closing that intention action gap so
you're much more likely to follow
through and this also mirrors like
what's called behavioral activation
therapy
it's like great like you can have a
patient have a lot of insight and be
like yeah maybe this is why i've been
depressed or this is why i'm upset and
like bells can go off and light bulbs
and you can be like oh my goodness
awesome but i've had patients do that
who have like renewed like understanding
and depth and like wow that's really
illuminating but it doesn't change their
behavior like they're still the couch
potato and they're still you know maybe
an insightful you know one but they're
still not doing anything but so so then
okay
behavioral activation is more around
okay like what actions are you doing to
you know what plans you want to make to
actually do the thing that you want to
do and it really is like that's what
their homework is is behavioral
activation stuff so you are
you know so i'm going to
write up my resume i'm going to make
that phone call i'm going to do the
follow-up call so they're actually
taking actions that then you know help
them feel stronger and i think those
positive actions are you know when we
feel paralyzed or like the world is you
know we're like these tumbleweeds are
going back to you know self efficacy
if we don't feel you know the kind of
the hat trick of maybe happiness is a
sense of autonomy
competence and relatedness you know that
sense that like you have a say in what
you do is autonomy um competence is that
you can you know you can probably you
can
what you try out you will succeed at and
relatedness is that sense of feeling
loved and i think all three are so
important
and
therapy sometimes lacks that competence
and autonomy part of it you can feel
related and loved and that you belong
but do you make how do you make somebody
or help them to feel competent and um
that they have autonomy in their lives
is that because it's
easier to make people feel good in a
therapy session that it's a little bit
more
chicken soup for the soul
type things inside as opposed to action
like it seems like
a lot of
the challenges that people
come up against would be fixed by just
focusing on action more than intention
and if action's an antidote to anxiety
which it seems like it is like
just
what's the one thing that you could do
as opposed to the 10 things that you
could think
i mean like at least just do one thing
to close that intention action gap like
what's the like what's the one thing to
get you closer or do the one thing that
like embodied vitality like embodied
resilience like what is that thing that
you care about that you can do
it's funny this old psychiatrist had
once it was a teacher of mine and he
said what do you think the point of
you know therapy is and i was like oh
you know so that's so you know you can
have it you know change your present you
said wrong and someone else said well
maybe it's you can change your future
and he said no wrong
the point of therapy is so you can
change your past
because we all have as like a story that
we've been sticking to we've got like
the two minute version the 10-minute
version the hour-long version of it
but you know we get so
so like sort of tethered to this
identity of like you know
my dad was a jerk my mom didn't talk to
me enough i you know whatever those
stories that we tell
and making you know realizing that
probably there's some truth to it but
it there isn't this the the what that
story you've been telling might be a
little bit distorted and sort of making
peace with that and i think it actually
does free you up in some way to be
thinking about your future and it frees
you up to take actions because you don't
feel like such a victim of
all of these things that have come at
you
why are people so resistant to change
you know it's baffling because you know
i think it's um
uh
uh with sam gilbert at uh at harvard who
all says you know we're all
that
that we're all we're human beings or
works in progress um who un who
mistakeably think that we're fully
formed and finished and
we're resistant to change and yet we're
changing constantly you know and so even
when you have like couples and couples
therapy so you can say to them like just
wait three months he's probably going to
change a little bit like don't you worry
because we're all changing but i think
we're passively changing and we're not
intentional about the way that we're
changing and it's obviously looking back
you can see how much you've changed i
mean
you have changed maybe not for the
better but you probably have changed
looking forward it's unimaginable how
much you are going to change but you
will so will you be intentional about
that change um and i i think to me
that's sort of i hope what therapy does
for people is kind of bending them in
the direction of goodness
but change is terrifying i mean i think
it's exactly what scares us we have this
illusion of certainty and this is who i
am and this is what i do people always
tell me like i am who i am you know they
come to therapy i [ __ ] hate that
sentence
like that sentence from people drives me
up the wall it reminds me so much of
that i've got a chip on the shoulder
about some of the um cultures of the
places that i grew up
and hearing someone
be so
they've they've become a prisoner of
their own
pre presumptions about their own life
and about everybody else
like i remember once i remember once i
was i was driving in this car must have
been when i was like 16 or 17 and it was
a
couple of lads i went to college with or
something
and the driver was a young young kid 17
or 18 just recently passed his test we
were going over a motorway in
middlesbrough which is just a
working-class town famous for having the
highest teen pregnancy rating in the uk
for a few years and not much else and i
remember him saying i'm never going to
leave t side me best place in the world
i thought you've been to corfu once and
then southampton on a holiday you
haven't seen anything of the world but
somehow this person and even then i
didn't really understand why it just
made me feel so ick i i it was such an
awful feeling and it stayed with me you
know 17 years later i've still got that
story because it it struck me that look
this this guy is so small-minded
and so closed off and it wasn't because
of a
a yearning a justified virtuous yearning
for familiarity it wasn't for something
that had run through in his mind he'd
seen the world and realized that home is
where we were where he wanted to be it
was because of this sort of walled off
fear of change and this sort of denial
that there was anything that the outside
world could teach him and this is how
you get
tall poppy syndrome in the uk where
people that decide to try and do
different things they get very quickly
cut down and um
yeah i hate that i i absolutely hate
that sentence it's i mean that must be
if i was a psychiatrist that would be my
trigger word if that happened like this
is the way i am and it's the way that
i'll always be that would be my that
that's the activation for what my
russian uh sub
secret agent subplot to to activate
it's no it's so it's sad and even like
the idea of like well you can't teach
you know old dogs new tricks and i i'm
yes you can you know and i'm always
amazed by people who have sort of
inflection points in their lives and
like at 50 they change jobs or they
you know and i think when we see people
often retire that sense of just being
unnecessary in the world or they're not
going to change or do anything more is
really difficult and we know people who
are what they call like adventurers or
continuers are far more fulfilled than
those who just become observers or
retreaters and
the the it's
you are going to be changing and to like
unlock that and it's such a sort of
weird wall to hide behind of like i am
who i am and it's really just like your
habits and your preferences that's all
it is it's illusion imagine identifying
with that like it's so crazy
but it's safe i mean in a way and and i
i think that people
come to therapy often with this like
interest in
they want like they sort of want to
change but when you sort of push against
those walls a little bit they're like oh
no no i am who i am i i'm a you know i'm
just not you know a relationship guy i'm
you know uh like this is how i have fun
or this is you know this is who i am and
it's such a
a limited way in you know of looking at
the world and looking at your life and
not seeing your potential and
possibility not just for yourself but
also for the other people you spend time
with you know because if you think like
that about yourself that's clearly how
your you know your mindset is around how
you see other people like they are who
they are and i i've loved being wrong
you know like there's been nothing
better than to be wrong about stuff and
you know even i think like we live in
this like world today where you you know
you have to like support one political
candidate or you have to think
you have to like join the narrative on
something and bring some like
intellectual humility to something and
being willing to have your like mind
changed and i've had patients who you
know i was a little bit more in that
camp of how people are who they are
somebody who would i'd seen like this
revolving door he had a serious alcohol
problem gone to rehab a thousand times
um and i was you know didn't really
think he would make it past a certain
age and one day i bump into him on the
street i haven't seen the guy in five
years and he's completely transformed he
looks different he's healthy and he
looked at me and he said you know what
because i was so like just gobsmacked by
this transformation he said you know dr
boardman people change and it's like
thank you thank you but and it's it's um
it was actually a gift him telling me
that i think in those days i used to be
really stuck in that place of like i
could almost like look at somebody and
come up with like a diagnosis like i
know the end of this movie
and um i think letting go of that
uncertainty for myself and for others is
really valuable
what
given the fact that you've studied
positive psychology what do you think
more people need to know
about
that about some of the takeaways from
that field of work that they don't
yeah i mean i just think the the focus
on um what's wrong is just the way i
think most of us do anyway we talked
about the psychotic effect earlier but
actually if you use your strengths in
meaningful ways and i think actually
figuring out what your strengths are you
know there's some you can do these
surveys they're free that just tell you
exactly like okay your top strength is
curiosity it's um
you know uh perseverance it's love of
beauty whatever that thing is
and then these studies that show that
okay now use your strength in a new way
every day for the next two weeks so you
can't just say like oh i'm curious i'm
going to you know you know read
something different like what's a new
way or maybe you're going to take a
different route home if you're going to
try different food maybe you're going to
you know
start learning a different language
whatever those things are i mean i think
that
we're you know in our lives we're you
know we'll often save and like changes
we want to make like oh i'd like to stop
smoking i want to lose weight it's these
things that we're kind of trying to take
away but like maybe i need to do more of
things that i'm good at and that i love
that i'm interested in and that you know
that bring me that bring me joy and i
think that that's something that was
never you know it was sort of considered
like icing on the cake when i was in
medical school like oh that's the stuff
that social workers deal with like
that's not something we really need to
focus on in people's lives but actually
what is the stuff that brings them joy
what makes them feel strong even you
know how do you help them find even
wellness within illness and you can you
can do that and interesting studies of
people have schizophrenia
there are some people who feel you know
who feel that they're happy and
fulfilled and in those lives and i i
used to never believe that was even
possible and there was a psychiatrist
who
she
she was a psychologist
a woman who it was in yale when she was
um in school and when she was i think
about 20 she had a psychotic break and
she
you know i i think was
sid stripped and was running naked
through the yale courtyards and her
parents were called and they said you've
got to take her out of school you know
she's schizophrenic she will probably
have um be hospitalized multiple times
but you need to reduce the stress in her
life in every way and you know um
uh you know she'll probably have her
maybe do like she could be a cashier
somewhere but that's about it and she
said her parents accepted um her
diagnosis but refused to accept her
prognosis in every way so she went back
to school she graduated had support had
had medication she went to oxford she
got a degree in mental health law um and
she went on to become this champion of
mental health law she won a macarthur
genius um grant a few years ago
and she said that her
studying law has helped her so much and
sort of figure out
you know it become useful in the world
and that even when sometimes her voices
get loud that she starts hearing she'll
use her legal training and say what
evidence do you have for that you know
so i think that there's so um you know
when we when we can actually
find
usefulness for even the things that
maybe hold us back and the things that
we think of as um tremendous parts of
like what we're weak and we're not good
at and we can apply actually what our
strengths are in meaningful ways in the
world and find meaningful work in some
way like she did that i think that's
sort of what positive psychology can
help you do is find wellness within your
illness and
you know i think sometimes people think
of it as two rainbows and unicorns kind
of thing and it's really not i mean i
think it's just looking at the opposite
of what traditional psychiatry and
medicine has been looking at is making
people like bringing people back to zero
what's your baseline and that's like
what i was good at doing i'd be like
okay someone will come into the
emergency room like what's your baseline
let me get you back here and uh and i
never it never occurred to me that i
could sort of you know get them beyond
that or even kind of give them some of
these other
uh like interventions and other
activities to work on it would help them
feel good even within what's going wrong
robert ploman guy that i had on this
monday behavioral genetics he talks
about the fact that our genes do not
predetermine but they do predispose
and with that he says
parenting parents
they matter but they don't make a
difference
so you can't really get your kids to do
anything your kids are going to do what
your kids are going to do and you can
either support them in that or not he
makes this analogy about if you
lost a child on a desert island and this
child was going to be a musician you'd
find him sort of cracking out tunes on
the back of coconuts and stuff like this
and
having that faith in your own
programming in a little way
is
is very interesting having sort of faith
in embodied knowledge this is something
that i have a talent with this is
something that i feel compelled to do
this is something that i'm really really
strong
strong at and sort of pulled toward
how can i utilize that um i still
haven't worked out how i combine that
with the fact that most of the values
that i think we absorb most of the
programming that we get from culture and
from society
is totally useless um i don't know how
to separate out the embodied stuff that
we should have faith in and the
programmed stuff that we get from
society but that's um
that's a challenge samantha boardman
ladies and gentlemen ready for anything
in the uk or everyday vitality in the
u.s if people want to check out your
stuff where should they go
positiveprescription.com
and i'm on twitter and instagram and all
of social media
thanks samantha
thank you so much for having me
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace
you